can a hamburger truly cure a hangover
we've created a lab to test the world's
greatest hangover Cheers and we're gonna
test them all I'm dr. Keller wertham the
doctor of internal medicine I'm Fran
Kranz I'm not a doctor but I've been
hung over a lot welcome to the GQ
hangover that my name is Jeff Danson I'm
a stand-up comedian what happened last
night why'd you drink and why I drank
beer and tequila and this is after one
year no no one already engaging in
bestiality that's my puppy pizza okay so
he's still alive those are yeah both on
you and pizza by the way yeah I know
okay how do you feel today job so you
know we kind of want to get a gauge on
how hungover you are before we go into
testing so we did some vital signs we
did urine tests to check your blood
pressure your pulse some coordination
and memory testing oh we have a very
scientific chart to sort of measure how
one who pills I'm probably here at six
now let's get let's get to the cure I'm
ready to eat so we've spent a little
time with Jeff I think it's fair to say
he's hungover he's not with us yeah he's
not all there he's not all there he's
got the classic signs of a hangover yeah
got low energy because his body isn't
making blood sugar he's got a bunch of
toxins in his blood that are making him
feel really crappy yeah messing with his
coordination absolutely he's got a high
blood pressure which has you know a sign
he's a little bit agitated basically
alcohol blocks a certain hormone that
keeps you from kind of recollecting the
water from your kidneys that you should
be holding on to and that is the primary
reason why you end up so dehydrated when
you're drinking a lot of alcohol so what
are we gonna give them we got a
beautiful juicy hangover burger we
should say that this burger is the
mother of all burgers for a hangover
cure I mean it's got a really fluffy
buns there's lots of sugar right in that
and it's got an egg which is actually a
special thing for a hangover it's got a
certain amino acid called cysteine in it
that actually helps you speed up your
metabolism of alcohol huh I think he's
gonna feel better and perform worse
one doctor's opinion this is my favorite
part so far so the funny thing is when
you're when you're hungover your
metabolic system is thrown off and it
produces this one hormone that makes us
crave fatty foods so you're actually
satisfying your desire to be
oh good how are you feeling
great great I didn't pay for this burger
let's see if it works so we're gonna see
how that burger did for your blood
pressure
it drops substantially it went from 150
to 130 so I think just like the pleasure
probably of getting some system drop
this blood pressure I hope the people at
home don't take away that burgers lower
your blood pressure because they don't
but maybe when you're hungover yes post
went down to 61 so you're more relaxed I
think we still need to test the motor
skills oh good last time we made it to
an eight let's see if you can beat it
oh no last one was I forgot so let's
break it down you went from an 8 to a 9
in the memory game that's what gets the
girl to go home with you interestingly
enough after a big greasy salty burger a
decrease in your blood pressure a
decrease in your pulse rate I mean you
certainly felt like more relaxed your
blood sugar stayed the same which was
great who cares like what changes the
numbers I want to know if you really
feel better yeah so before I was at a
six now I'm at true
I feel good about myself I feel
extremely ready to go to sleep
first of all I'm floored that a big
juicy burger and fries brought his blood
pressure down I mean it's gotta make
doctors everywhere pretty pissed off
definitely sending the wrong message so
looking at all the results together you
know his numbers how he did on the on
the memory test I'm gonna have to give
the juicy greasy burger a B because he
feels better he did a little bit better
in his vital signs and the memory game
but it really didn't address dehydration
which is like the main thing we got to
worry about right well I mean I gotta
give it a better grade than that I mean
that's such a tried-and-true for me that
the the burger the greasy food I'm gonna
go eh - bottom line is he feels
substantially better and we set him home
a happier person
I'm Fran Kranz and dr. Keller thanks for
visiting the GQ hangover lab
if you want to know more about hangovers
how to prevent them and how to cure them
subscribe to the channel